prepare yourself me father weak is down
On est tous.. euh.. enfin on tous dans le même bateau
Et si...euh........
et si parfois ca déraille
Bah tout le monde empâtit disons
Mais...euh.....
Mais voila après c'est sûr qu'il y a
Qu'il y a des ratés et quand on les voit à l'ecran
C'est....
On se dit bah "Pourquoi?"
Pourquoi avoir garder ça
après moi je... (bafouillage et recherche de mot *stressée*)
Après il y a personne a blâmer ou tout le monde
Et puis..
Après c'est sur que bon
La réaction a été.. j'ai trouvé  un peu disproportionné
parce que c'est dur de voir.. de se voir résumer à ça
et...
et euh..
quand
quand voilà quand je fais du mieux que je peux disons pour
trouver l'authenticité dans chaque personnage
et se voir résumer à une scène
ça a pas été forcément hyper agréable.
Ton dernier bon film c'était Taxi, madame
la seule chose moins crédicle que ton rap c'est ta mort dans Batman
C'est nul !
Après oui non mais c'est sûr qu'il faut savoir rire de tout
et puis surtout
fin... euh..
au delà d'avoir du recul, il y a des choses vraiment plus graves dans la vie que ça
même s'il y a des choses qui peuvent blesser et que
mais bon ça n'a pas été plus loin que
j'ai pas non plus été au bout du rouleau non plus quoi
j'ai juste trouvé la réaction disproportionnée
et ça me fait du bien à moi la première d'en rire quoi